[Music]
i have great pleasure to introduce our
first speaker today uh he is my
colleague
a good friend of mine and so without
further ado
like us all to join me in welcoming alex
gold
[Applause]
hey everybody uh like kelly said my name
is alex
i'm here to talk today about end-to-end
data science deployment with our
markdown
shiny plumber and pins uh the slides and
code are available online at rstd.io
deploy 2020 although as i'm saying this
i'm realizing that the slides are not
there yet
but they will be so look forward to that
um so this
this story starts as all great stories
do with with a shiny app
um and this this shiny app in particular
uses the capital bike share data so if
you're
if you don't know what the capital bike
share is the system of docked
uh bicycles in washington dc that's
that's what they look like that's what
the docs look like
you can rent a bike from a dock and
write it to a different dock and dock it
there
um and so you know what what i'm going
to try and do with this shiny app is
predict
the number of bikes at different
stations at different times so
uh where's my window here's my window so
this is what the app looks like
uh i've got a map of washington dc uh i
can click on a particular station you'll
see this is that 21st and m
and if i scroll down now i can see the
number of bikes that are available
at that station or predicted to be
available at that station without the
next 24 hours
uh important maybe if i wanted to go get
a bike in dc at 8 pm tonight because
there are going to be none
at 21 m too bad uh
so let's let's talk a little bit about
sort of how how this app works
uh so the capital bike share uh
organization makes available an api
that provides real-time bike data how
many bikes are at each station
right now uh available on the api and
i'm going to import this using an
markdown document from there i'm going
to build an xg boost model to do all my
prediction for me i'm going to do that
also in our markdown
i'm going to serve this this model with
a plumber api and if you're if you're
interested in plumber i'm not going to
talk a lot more about it right now
but hang out because like the rest of
this track is going to be a lot of
plumbers so that'll be awesome
uh and then of course i'm serving this
to the the client app at the end and so
you know i had this app but but i wanted
to to take it further right it just
lives on my machine
i don't have to like walk my computer to
people um
to show them my app and so i knew where
i wanted to get to was you know
my shiny app is available all the time
to whoever
wants it the uh the model gets retrained
every day right like weather's gonna
change
different seasons i wanna be able to to
have uh uh you know the model retraining
periodically
and i need you this data import every 20
minutes it's real-time data so like once
it's gone
it's gone and so i want to get those
real-time data pull them in
and and store them somewhere so that i
can do my predictions as you know sort
of a time series or panel kind of
kind of thing um so
i i'm there but that leads to like a
whole bunch of questions what what
should i
prioritize while i'm doing this there
are all these things that i could
want to do uh as i'm trying to like you
know sort of deploy this app and and
uh you know add some horsepower and
that's these are like
hard scary big questions and really what
they boil down
to is you know is my deployment
sophisticated enough am i doing it
for real or or not um of course i
i then you know did what i sometimes do
when i'm procrastinating which was i
started watching star wars
uh just because you know why not do that
and you all might know this guy
uh green big ears talks funny
uh he's the jedi master yoda of course
and and he says this line in the middle
of one of the movies
uh size matters not look at me judge me
by my size do you and i thought this was
really appropriate right like
if you just sub in the word like
sophistication here right like this is a
great way to think of
why do we care about deploying shiny
apps and of course we care because we
want to increase
value we want to provide value
sophistication is irrelevant right
are you providing value is the right
question and so
um how do we deploy to to increase value
how how was i going to do that
um and and so there were sort of three
principles that i took as as my guides
and the first one was that
i wanted to make my content accessible
and what that meant is that people who
should have access to the content can
get it when they need it and somewhere
that they know where to find it
uh the second thing was reproducible
right can i can i reliably
understand how the content exists
why it is the way it is can i sort of
audit it and then and then secure and
that's sort of the inverse of accessible
right should people who
don't people who shouldn't have access
don't have access that's
that's uh that's pretty important um
so you know the question is how do i get
there and this is honestly
uh not a trivial problem right uh in
particular
in between those important train steps
with my data i have to store that data
somewhere and then in between training
and serving the model i have to store
that model
somewhere and until recently this wasn't
a solved problem um
you know i i could put it the analysis
data in a database if i if i have one
handy if i have write privileges to one
that's
that's fine but if i if i don't or if i
don't want to put it in a database for
some reason there kind of was no good
answer there and and similarly with
with modeling um there was kind of no
good answer
so i i went i went back to star wars
went back to uh
you know not working on this because
that was that was easier
and of course yoda um came to my came to
my rescue
yet again uh saying you know when
hopeless the task seems
come out with a sweet new r package
someone will like
it's inevitable you know and of course
that was true uh the pins package is a
new package by javier larashi he's here
at r studio
and this is this is a super cool package
i'm super excited about it
basically what it lets you do is take
something an r object
put it somewhere else and then get it
back when you want it this is sort of
the essence of the pins package but
let's go into a little more detail about
exactly how it works
so i'm going to start off with my my r
my r studio session and i have an object
i want to save you can think like a data
frame
it could also be a model it could be any
sort of s3 compliant object
and you know i have a board also and my
board is where i'm going to save it pins
currently supports a bunch of different
boards um so rcu connect kaggle github
azure google cloud platform
s3 or a website uh javier is constantly
adding new boards i will also add so if
you
want something that isn't here like put
it on github and i'll probably have it
done before the end of conf it's
kind of incredible uh but that aside it
supports a lot of different places you
can put your data great
so uh it's really easy to use as well
you put
your data onto the board with the pins
pin command
and get it back with the pins pin get
commands let me let me show you how this
works just to be a little more
a little more concrete here um
so the the way this works is that i've
got
my uh my pins let me make this bigger
for y'all
better it's probably easier to see right
uh so i'm gonna load up the pins package
i'm going to register my board in this
case i'm registering our studio
connection that just this just means you
know this is a board you can talk to
with to the r station so it's going to
register takes just a moment
and then i'm going to pin my data to the
board right it's pin
whatever the object is i'm pinning the
name of the object and the board where
it's going
and it's going taking a moment to load
and so here i am in the connections pane
and you can see that like any other type
of connection like a database connection
it loads up right here
and if what i've pinned is a data frame
i can actually see what's going on there
i can see the different fields
in my data frame and i can also go over
here i can preview the table i can see
the first thousand rows this is mt cars
they're only 32 but you know
you could see up to a thousand and then
if i want to get the pin
back i just run this pin get command
saving it to a local a local file and
now i've got mt cars back and to me
this is this is so so cool because
what what's happened now is instead of
having to email around data
or having to save data somewhere and
then tell everybody where it is and you
know version two final actually final
alex fine
right none of that right the person
needs to know the name of the board or
the the url of the board and they need
to know what the name of the
pin is and then what they get when they
do a pin get is
always the newest version right this is
the thing that's really exciting is like
the newest version is always available
on this pin
um so
oops
so so the question is sort of you know
what are good things depending on what
are bad things
obviously you don't want to just like
store every single r object you've ever
used
um in in a pin so uh some
again wisdom from yoda uh just before
luke goes off to fight vader at cloud
city and
it's a disas anyway um before that
though yoda gives him some very some
very sage advice
uh best considered a caching mechanism
pins are
and and and what this means hey it's
kind of you know this movie came out in
1980 and
this package came out in 2020 so like
this is very impressive to begin with
but uh even more impressive that he's
right and so
uh you know you generally don't want to
save your data of record in a pin
right it's it's not a database it
doesn't have all the like
bells and whistle of a database being
able to audit not a database replacement
um what pins are great for is is they're
great for something
that you could compute at the time or
you could get at the time but it's
easier to store it somewhere right you'd
rather cache it
rather than uh recreating it on demand
and so there are three attributes that
good candidates for a pin have and that
is that they're relatively small say
like
a gigabyte there's no hard rule but a
gigabyte is a good a good rule of thumb
they're reused that you actually want
this thing over and over and over again
uh in different pieces of your content
and that they're they're current
right you want the tip of the pin you
only care about the newest version if
you care about archival versions
a pin is not a great choice but if you
care about just the newest one that's
really good
and again you know pins are for things
you can recreate
you know it's not for your data of
record um that that's not a great choice
i mean if you do it whatever i'm not
going to stop you but officially
recommending against that
um so let me show you let's go back to
our our bike app here
and and just show a little bit of where
pins show up in this app oh we're very
zoomed in
and so you know here we have the app
right rinder this is what our app looks
like we've got a map we click on the map
we get
the prediction of the number of bikes at
different stations throughout
um and so there are a couple places that
pins show up here and i'm gonna be very
honest this app is quite
the code that goes in here is quite
large uh it demos a lot of different
things so i'm gonna sort of like go real
quick through a couple little things
here
and ignore a lot of the rest of the code
so that's just how it's gonna go sorry
uh and so when i go to my my pins here
um i have my my ingest and tidy part
here right this is where i'm pulling in
from the api
so i'm i'm registering with both my
database connection
right that's this that's this line 15.
and in line 16 and 17 i'm registering
the pins board because i'm going to put
things in both places
so first i'm going to do is i'm going to
pull down from the api the number of
bikes
oh interesting maybe i should run this
line first there we go
um and so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to pull down the number of bikes
and you can see this is just a data
frame that came back
all this code in here is just sort of
interpreting the api call
and you know what i'm doing is i'm just
pulling in the station id and the number
of bikes available these are really
sort of the most important fields to me
this is going to be like my target when
i'm doing my my machine learning
and then i'm going to write this to my
database right that's getting written to
my database and that's actually
scheduled to happen on our studio
connect every 20 minutes so that's great
taking care of
the next piece though and this is what
i'm going to pin so this data frame
this data frame this is the station
information so this is it's those ids
those station ids which are just numeric
but i have the names here which is what
i'm putting you know pop up there in the
app
i'm putting up the latitude and
longitude which i'm going to use both to
put them on the map
and also as a feature in my machine
learning model as well as the capacity
of the stations which is also an
important feature
of my machine learning model and this is
a perfect candidate for a pin it's small
it's less than 600 rows
i reuse it several different times
across this piece of of content
and i always want the most current
version right on my map i don't want to
be showing stations that don't exist or
that have moved or anything like that
and so this is what i'm going to be
pinning in my code
similarly then when i go on to build my
my xg boost model um
again i'm going to skip a lot through
some code here but you can see that i'm
pulling in another pin here this is my
modeling parameters actually that i'm
writing elsewhere
but what i really want to show is down
here i'm training my model with with
parsip
parsnip xgb train and then what i'm
saving here
is this list object right this is like
this could be a formal s3 object it's
not it's just a list
right but i have my model i'm saving
some metadata with it as well the
training date the splitting date
between my testing and training set and
the recipe that i'm using from the
recipes package
to actually make my training data and
then i'm pinning that
here onto rcu connect and this is super
useful right now i have a really good
way
to know what i've done and then last my
plumber api that's serving those
predictions
uh i've got you know my model i'm
reading it in here
and then all this code basically is just
sort of interpreting
the uh the input from the api and making
sure it's ready to be fed into the model
and then down here right i'm running
that predict command on that model
that's that's from the pin
um and this is you know purring away on
on our studio connect and so you know i
can
come here to the swagger uh interface
and get back
you know these are the predictions first
station 75 i don't know
what station that is but that's why i
have the the other one the other pin
with the station names
so um that's that's how pins sort of fit
into
into this app so now i've got a solution
for this right for my analysis data i
can do it in a database
or in a pin for my model i can do it in
a pin
um one thing i do want to say is like
these are just slots
and you can put whatever you want into
these slots so for example uh you know
if you're if you're using some model in
python or some import model method in
python
you can totally do that and use
reticulate to go back and forth between
r and python super easily
um if if what you're serving isn't a
model if it's you know plots
or just some kind of counting right that
the same principle totally
works uh and when you're sharing right
if you're if what you've got is an r
markdown document that you want to
render and email out or something like
that
again think of these as slots uh you
know
my version happened to be our market on
our markdown plumber shiny app but yours
can be whatever you want
okay so pins has really helped me a lot
make this this content more accessible
more reproducible but i haven't really
addressed security at all and that's
that's a really important piece here
uh the the security of my app and so of
course i went back to yoda
and you know in return of the jedi as
yoda is dying fading away after 800
years of
of training jedi knights witnessing the
downfall okay
um sorry i really like star wars uh
he gives this one final piece of advice
to luke and he says deploy to the right
server
and secure your data will be uh which
you know
i think is very very prescient of him uh
and so you know
you can do this in in an open source way
if you know that's that's what you're
more comfortable doing for this
important training step
you know put it on a server any server
that has r works uh you can use a cron
job if you want to schedule it
um for your analysis date and your model
you can use you know if you have a
database for the database stuff or a
pins board i showed there like a whole
bunch of options right
for serving the model um any server with
r again can work
um you do have some things you have to
be delicate with here around around how
auth works
right so you can do that with networking
rules you could put a proxy in front of
it
you can like route it through a lambda
gateway to take care of api keys
you have lots of options but you're
going to want to do something to secure
this
this api and then for sharing you have a
lot of options if it's an rmarkdown
document
either a website or a rendered document
netlify is a great choice
shiny server open source is is available
to you and shiny apps at i o is also an
option which
is not open source but is relatively uh
affordable so
you know that that can be a really good
option here if you're doing like a
private thing or something that's for
for your own use
um of course we see a lot of
organizations that sort of struggle with
pieces of this
either they don't want to manage this
many sort of separate pieces um they
don't their their it organizations don't
want to manage
stuff in r we see that a lot that's
that's totally fine and so and so of
course sort of easy mode here
is our professional product our studio
connect and that takes care of a lot of
these pieces
for you right it it can deal with the
api keys
it can deal with scheduling the markdown
documents uh it can deal with securing
the the plumber apis it can deal with
you know accessibility controls and that
kind of stuff and you can put pins on
our studio connect
um so this can be a really a really
useful way uh
to to to do all of this so
uh big takeaways um when you are
thinking about deploying
content uh the the top three things to
really
optimize for are accessibility uh
reproducibility and security
right if you're hitting these three keys
you're probably increasing value
um with what you're doing as opposed to
just
adding sophistication um while you're
doing that uh our markdown shiny plumber
and pins are good friends of yours and
of course may the force be with you
thanks everybody
i'm gonna put this down all right all
right so
uh i failed to mention the top of things
here but if you have
questions we're gonna continue using
slido as we did in the keynotes so
we're in grand ballroom b so if you have
a question
go to the same slido page select grand
ballroom b and you can enter your
questions there or
vote on questions that are already asked
there so i'm going to ask alex some
questions here since we have a couple
minutes
maybe this was covered in the last half
of your presentation but you
do you want to readdress how pins is
different from a well organized
shared file system with correct acls
yeah that's a that's a great question um
it to be honest under the hood it's not
that different right you have the same
kind of
uh control and access controls the the
main difference is that it's a very r
centric
answer and so you can from within r
address those objects
uh without having to go through the
hassle of figuring out you know how your
shared file system works
uh finding things and that sort of thing
so from from an i.t perspective maybe
not that different uh but from the
perspective of an r developer
it's a very different sort of
development experience it's much more
straightforward
yeah this next one we we get a lot so
i'm
happy to ask it here what's the the
benefit of using a plumber api
for saving the object to s3 and then
calling it with a shiny app
oh that's a great question i love that
question um
there are a couple benefits um one is
that that you can the biggest benefit to
me
and this happens in several different
ways is that it decouples the logic of
serving the the model from the logic of
displaying whatever you're displaying or
doing something else with it so you
decouple those things
and that makes your life easier it makes
your life easier in a couple ways one of
them is is purely like from a code
perspective
it makes it easier to write the code
because you write your plumber api to
serve the model
you write your shiny app or whatever it
is to consume the model and you get to
sort of separate those those concerns
which which is really nice
the other piece from a performance
perspective you can test those two
things independently
right you can test the plumber api with
say the load test package which i think
some people might be talking about next
uh and then you can test the shiny app
separately right you can decouple
both the coding and the performance
issues between the api
and the uh the app which is great
excellent okay next is there a limit to
the amount of data
you should be using with pins
it depends on which board you're using
some of those boards do have limits to
how much you can save
um you know my suggestion would be that
if you're saving more than a gigabyte's
worth of data
there's probably a better solution for
for what you're doing
um and that's totally a rule of thumb
not a
you know a real thing but um just in
general if you're finding yourself doing
more than that
uh you're you're probably saving an
object that's bigger than pins really is
designed for
um one one thing that can be helpful is
if you're saving model objects often the
model objects package up a lot of stuff
with it that you don't necessarily want
like the training data
and that could make your your model
really big and you know sort of inflate
the size there is a package called
butcher
um like you know person who makes meat
cuts
uh that you can use to sort of chop out
some of the stuff in your model object
you don't want and just save like
actually the model so if you're saving
models that can be a useful thing to do
do one more here i like this one as well
is there a reason your import and model
training code
is in our markdown files instead of
playing our scripts
yes that's a great question i love it
when things that i put in the
presentation and then took out because i
didn't have time
come back in questions um yeah so i
really love our markdown for for two
main reasons um one is that it
encourages literate programming
that is interspersing uh code and prose
right because
you have just like a place to write
prose it doesn't even be comments you
just
write it and it's great um the other
reason that you have a record of what
you did so when you come back later
and your something has gone awry with
your model um you have output there
with the code of what actually happened
unlike if it's just an r script and then
whatever happened was totally ephemeral
and it's gone forever
well everyone please join me in thanking
alex again thanks for buddy
[Music]